dos meses después de que los
socialdemócratas derrotaron por estrecho
margen a los conservadores en las
elecciones generales el futuro canciller
de alemania anunció nuevo acuerdo de
coalición
nos une la creencia en el progreso y en
que la política puede lograr algo bueno
nos une la voluntad de mejorar el país
de hacer que avance y de mantenerlo
unidos
no se trata de políticas de mínimo común
denominador sino de políticas de alto
impacto
el acuerdo instalará la primera
coalición federal del país entre el
partido socialdemócrata los liberales y
el partido verde en la nueva agenda se
buscará poner fin a la pandemia de kobe
y 19 eliminar el uso de la energía a
base de carbón para 2030 y adherirse al
estricto freno constitucional de la
deuda pública alemana para evitar que se
dispare a esto se suma el
fortalecimiento de la soberanía europea
y la reforma migratoria en cuanto a los
puestos en el gabinete la líder de los
verdes ocupará el ministerio de
relaciones exteriores y otro ecologista
asumirá un nuevo puesto que combina
política económica y medioambiental el
liberal cristian línder será el nuevo
ministro de finanzas los
socialdemócratas irán a los ministerios
del interior defensa construcción salud
y trabajo se espera que la coalición
tripartita apruebe el acuerdo en los
próximos diez días y que se les asuma el
próximo 6 de diciembre